the drive does I think it's appointed  travel consequence-free failure it's  important for them to basically if they  delve into something that they're really  good that continued continue doing it  there might be there might be some not  just use in case they get so fixed over  something that isn't really necessarily  good for them but only but preferably in  a way that utilizes nonviolent  communication and that doesn't  discourage them from seeking further  feedback from you because a lot of times  people are super discouraged from  seeking feedback from you because you've  criticized them in a way that makes them  uncomfortable and adverse to you from  now on yeah correct that's actually  really important